My name is Luke Stark, I'm a Berkman Fellow
this year, I'm also a post-doc in sociology
at Dartmouth College.
And one research question I'm really interested
in this year is how we think about expanding
the ethical horizons of science and technology,
especially around STEM education, computer
science, and engineering.
I think it's important because these technologies
that get designed and built by computer scientists
and engineers have a huge impact on our world.
And they have a lot of say in how social life
gets organized these days.
So I think it's important for all of us to
understand the social and ethical implications
of those technologies.
I remember when I was in my early 20s, I had
a job working for the government of Ontario
in communication.
And I sort of realized that the politicians
were really interested in how newspapers got
laid out.
They cared about where the headline was on
the page, how many column inches they got.
And it just underscored to me the truth of
Marshall MacLuhan's axiom about the medium
being the message.
That the newspaper, which is also kind of
a technology was important to the way these
politicians' values and messages got out.
That really helped spark my interest.
I think in the last year or so there have
been so many stories in the news about why
the ethics of technology are important.
Debates about "fake news," about persuasion,
about the way that social media shaped electoral
politics and that kind of thing.
I think a lot of people realized the importance
of these questions in their every day digital
media use before 2017.
But I think it's really hard to ignore those
things now.